hi I'm Wolfgang Puck and today I'm gonna
show you how to make great Cavan a
braised short ribs it's gonna blow your
mind they're so delicious the first
thing I always do is marinate the meat
it tenderizes it and it gives it flavor
you know years ago when I came to
America
everybody was only eating steaks or
chops nobody used the lesser cuts of
meat because people didn't know how to
prepare them really well after 35 years
short ribs have become very very popular
so today
braising or slow cooking has become in
fashion again I make their short trips
sometimes on Sunday at home because it
takes a long time to cook so normally I
come home at 6 o'clock at night and I
cook something really fast but on Sunday
when I spend all day at home I just make
them put them in the oven and at 6:30 we
sit down and have dinner and everybody
loves it now the next step we're going
to flour them and then we're gonna saute
them why do i flour it we all know that
when you flour meat it rounds better we
want to brown the meat because you get
so much more flavor alright put olive
oil in a pan and wait until it gets
smoking hot alright the meat should be
nice and brown let's look at it that's
what we want beautiful caramelization
see that's perfect and then we're gonna
Brown our vegetables in here I love my
braised short ribs because they really
remind me of home cooking it's comfort
food that's the way I feel when I eat my
short ribs and most of it it's actually
much easier to do than what people sink
alright bring that to a boil and then
we're gonna add the meat now you're
gonna be sure cooking your meat in
liquid like that it does not gonna dry
out it's gonna be nice moist tender and
juicy you have to be careful you know my
hand they are so used to the heat after
all these years I can touch it at home
use your glove or a tower you can set it
or if you have a time I especially go to
the movies when you're gonna come
you're gonna have a delicious meal oh
look at that
mmm smells delicious use a fork and if
the fork goes in with no resistance at
all you know your short rib gonna be
nice and tender oh my God look at that I
have to taste a little bit mmm I'm from
Austria so I love much potatoes so I
always serve them with some mashed
potatoes but you can serve it with
noodles with fettuccine with Italy Soto
you decide what you serve it with you
know short ribs is a great way to save
money they don't cost as much as a steak
but they are even more delicious than a
steak mmm I think I'm gonna eat two
portions of that it is so delicious oh
yes
[Music]
you
[Music]